Safran beluga caviar truffles and bonnet
potatoes are just some of the world's
most expensive foods weight potatoes is
that right guys it says here on the
script potatoes potato seriously welcome
to nor Monte air a tiny island off the
Atlantic coast of France this is the
only place you can find the king of
potatoes His Majesty love bomb mount but
if you want to eat them fresh you've got
to be quick as they're only available
for ten days a year this is Rudy he's a
potato farmer so what makes the unload
of nwandi air so special for these spuds
it's a Desilu studios for premium
[Music]
ah sweet little girl is a doctor Anatole
no I'm on the subliminal that they are
incalculable new definition all the
farmers on the island are part of
cooperative they do with treating
cleaning selling and sending all over
Europe
[Music]
Nicolas is the director he makes sure
everything runs smoothly he really loves
these potatoes Odie Odie
Timo Bernhard namuci hello MA sorry
hello le fragile NEPA mechanism epoch
Saco do sombrio
de l'homme c'est la la I called Aleppo
not Sofia dustman Dylan aunt Sophie
unique most residual now I hope you're
sitting down because in 1996 these
pricey potatoes fetch the auction an
insane amount
drumroll roughly five hundred dollars
per pound luckily for me nowadays bonnet
potatoes aren't gonna break the bank
fetching more like five dollars per
pound which is still a lot for a bag of
potatoes sail upon the television
see a unison total na zdravi artisanal
they don't lipid it associate affair
since TFS another oh no la guarda
Alfonso - table table a pass to Apollo
vo we will all cease your
donatina net worth is only one traveler
[Music]
once the harvest is complete an annual
bonnet festival is held here the golden
potatoes are traditionally served with
grilled sardines so holiday taste see
soprano built-in pommes de terre a vicar
Angra Seifer from the Terre des hommes
you were in severe shipping al menos
most paper mache rigor llamo Fisk in
Napa Hankou dzasta haunt me on a film of
the dual the Pope Lizzy her daughter
akiza Nate so there we have it the king
of potatoes thank you your majesty
[Music]